[MUSIC]
Growing up, my dad gave my elder brother
and me any spare change he had, so
we could buy the newest technology
of that time, a desktop computer for
when we went to college.
Every day, he would come out from work,
put the rupee coins in our hands, and
we would run into our rooms and
put this money in our piggy banks.
After a couple of years,
we had decent amount of money.
It was August of 2002, I was 12 years old
then, sitting in my room and working on
my homework, when my dad stormed into the
room, and he was upset like never before.
He went straight to the piggy bank,
picked it up and smashed it to the ground.
He then took the money and left the room.
I was shocked.
Unsure of what had just happened,
I went to the ground
to pick up the broken pieces of piggy bank
and look if there was any money left.
There was none.
It was when I realized our family was
at the bottom of the economic pyramid.
While we were there,
my dad had no stable job for
years, he had no college degree either.
So when this machine tools
workshop ran out of business,
he went hustling to find a next job,
so he could run the family.
With no history of borrowing, he was
labeled risky and costly, and was turned
away by local banks, leaving him no
option but to take a desperate measure.
It may sound cliche, but
that broken piggy bank has become my
symbol of shattered dreams for my family
and many families around the world trying
to break the vicious cycles of poverty.
As a teenager,
it was frustrating to see newspapers
claim the economy had grown many-fold.
While we were at the very same
place despite years of hard work,
I wondered if a family was
even part of the economy.
Our financial struggles continued
until I graduated from college and
found a job at a bank.
Yes, a bank.
The system that once rejected us
has now become a family's lifeline.
Isn't that an irony?
Or is it what banks and
businesses are supposed to do?
Provide a lifeline to
the community around them.
I worked at this bank and
provided a comfortable life to my family.
But I couldn't erase the image of
broken piggy bank from my heart.
I wondered how many families around this
world are taking desperate measures,
only to see themselves stuck in a loop.
So in 2016, I decided to tackle this
problem by creating a technology product
that to provide micro credit
to unbank families in India.
One of the first customers was Sunil,
wanted a loan for
$500 to pay for his College fee and
continue with education.
He had good grades from his high school.
And earned a small income by working
part time at the food delivery company.
He and his family lived in a shanty house
in the city outskirts of Bangalore.
His dad drove a taxi and
earned $200 a month.
When Sunil and his dad went to
the nearest bank to apply for a loan,
they were rejected.
The reason they were rejected was because
of the risky income profile of his family.
And there was no profit to
be made of a small loan.
Without technology, he could apply for a
loan from the comfort of his mobile phone
by taking photographs of his documents and
submitting an online application.
It was approved instantly, and
he could enroll in college the next day.
Where the banks are unprofitable loan.
Our technology could see an opportunity.
Using mobile touch points we
reduce the cost structure and
reinvented the business model of a loan.
Our machine learning algorithms could
crunch through his bank accounts and
mobile data and saw an opportunity and
provided a small loan.
And the result He paid back
the loan in just nine months.
We give thousands of such loans,
loans that help taxi drivers,
small business merchants,
restaurant owners, pay for
the kids school fee and
advance the family forward.
Families that were traditionally
ignored by the banks,
are now able to access loans,
dream big and progress in life.
Today, Sunil is a proud first
generation graduate of his family.
He has a job as a car sales
representative and earns $600 a month.
He has access to formal banks and
health care and
doesn't have to take desperate
measures to take care of his family.
The impact I had on Sunil's life showed
me that technology can break traditional
business models and benefit billions
of people at the bottom of the pyramid.
There is hope.
What was not possible many years ago when
my family suffered, is possible today.
Thanks to mobile phones and technology.
The upward mobility that Sunil saw is
a resounding example of how removing
barriers to financial access
can turn things around for
people at the bottom of the pyramid.
And there are more than 4 billion people
waiting at the bottom of the pyramid
making less than $1500 a year.
And looking to overcome
barriers in finance,
healthcare, education and employment.
And it's not a problem specific to
India or other developing countries.
Take United States for example,
over the last 30 years,
the top 10% of the American Civil
wealth grew by 200% a staggering 200%.
Whereas the bottom 50% remained at the
same place, what do we all do about this?
From here on,
I can see the world going in two ways.
One, companies and individuals don't
think about these 4 billion people, they
think is the government's responsibility
to address this no, it does.
Two, there's resonates with me.
Well, as business leaders,
we embrace reality.
We may not be able to get rid
of poverty completely, but
we can do our best to remove
the systemic barriers in our society.
And that is the path I choose
to go down in my career.
If you're an entrepreneur,
I urge you to create technology solutions
that would remove the economic
asymmetries our world is in.
It is difficult, but not impossible to
create profitable businesses doing this.
If you're an investor, I urge you to
bank bold ideas and commit to them
over long periods of time and not just
look for short term opportunities.
In addition to financial returns,
it's time investors looked at economic
inclusion created by their investments.
When I moved to the Bay Area,
I was excited that I was stepping into
the technological future a perfect place.
I saw self driving cars,
delivery robots and drones.
But I also saw that while he was far
from reality, a far from perfect place.
Last year, I took an Uber ride
from San Francisco Airport.
I started a conversation
with the driver and
realized he was a college
dropouts student.
As we turn onto the palm drive,
he got excited and
asked me what I was doing here.
I told him I was a student,
his eyes lit up immediately and
said he too wanted to come to Stanford.
And here he is,
working two jobs a day to make ends meet.
If I don't have conversations like those,
I fear I might live in a bubble and
be blind to people living
from paycheck to paycheck.
We all live in a bubble.
We don't see janitors, drivers and
the lives of 4 billion people breaking
the piggy banks every single day.
Let's use technology that
can break barriers so
people don't have to
break their piggy banks.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]